pero que toda una invitación a nuestros
televidentes para que lean el libro y se
queden con toda la información pero a
manera de abrebocas cuéntenos porque
usted dice que los agentes del área
operaron en completa impunidad e
ilegalidad
bueno muchas gracias por tenerme hoy
aquí en su espacio es un libro que trata
100 años de historia del narcotráfico en
méxico a la luz de la historia de los
agentes antinarcóticos de eeuu en méxico
y un poco lo que muestra este libro es
la forma ilegal y en algunos casos
criminal en la cual es tratar gente se
operaron por ciento ciento y pico de
años que en nuestro país en méxico
tienen la américa latina y el globo y
como esos operativos encubiertos de la
dea contribuyeron al boom del
narcotráfico en méxico y en américa
latina
lo que señalo en este libro y espero que
el lector o la lectora pueda encontrar
es que las métricas de la dea los
decomisos los arrestos no necesariamente
van con las métricas que están bien para
méxico y el objetivo en méxico es
reducir la violencia eso muchas veces va
lejano digamos al objetivo de la dea y
de las agencias de arco ticos de eeuu
son dos intereses completamente
contrapuestos y en algunos casos incluso
llegan a yuxtaponer
y qué datos nos puede adelantar de estas
métricas porque son diferentes
al área le conviene tener muchos
decomisos le conviene tener muchos
arrestos que con eso pagan sus pensiones
con eso generan también más dinero para
la propia organización y está muy bien
el problema es que para mí eso no
debería ser la forma en la que se mide
el fracaso o el éxito de la estrategia
tienen la cantidad de muertos y eso
termina dejando en nuestro país las
métricas de la liga pues son el fracaso
son el fracaso de méxico y el libro cien
años de espías y drogas lo que intenta
hacer es hacer esa crítica la guerra
contra las drogas y sobre todo apunta en
los que se benefician saben que se
benefician de la guerra contra natura en
particular al ataque de antinarcóticos y
cuál es la gran lección que deja para
méxico y para los países
latinoamericanos la historia de un siglo
que usted cuenta
la gran lección es que los países en
américa latina y empiezo por méxico
tienen que ser capaces de tener
políticas soberanas en lo que respecta
al actuar de agentes antidrogas y no
solamente antidrogas sino también de
inteligencia y de otras agencias en
nuestros en nuestros países y no puede
ser que la cooperación ampare este tipo
de dinámicas criminales y francamente
violentas